invité de notre journal une autre
chanteuse qui elle revient de tourner et
non pas d'angleterre mais de belgique et
de suisse avant un récital de cinq jours
à la salle pleyel à paris france gall
bonsoir dans ce cadre nettement plus
intimiste que le palais omnisports de
bercy vous allez interpréter pour la
première fois sur scène certaines
chansons de michel berger composait pour
françoise hardy pour johnny hallyday ou
encore pour fabienne thibeault avant de
vous retrouver tout de suite un petit
aperçu des répétitions à pleyel
en somme
sympa non
tu
à
pour l'étape niché dans les rues
atteint d'un loup
les insultes
on n'a qu'à appeler ça aucune
bon
il court toujours
m
maintenant
je suis obligé de me pencher pour voir
en répétition
bonsoir france gall vous espériez
beaucoup avec michel berger chanter à
pleyel ça s'est jamais fait en fait d'un
poste un peu un rêve qui se réalise pour
vous partir de demain
c'est une grande chance oui c'est vrai
que c'est une salle merveilleuse qui
était fermée depuis presque vingt ans à
la musique de notre époque donc en fait
on a toujours eu envie de la faire mais
tout le monde a eu envie de la faire
donc voilà je pense que tout le monde va
la faire maintenant parce que c'est
c'est une vraie salle fait pour la
musique c'est le seul beaucoup plus
intimiste que bercy c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire
et pour l'autre le vin soit 7,1 du mois
et puis le moment bercy vont y avait il
faut bien le dire un contexte
psychologique très difficile on est en
france et projet vous aviez parlé de
votre cancer la maintenance d'une sorte
de renaissance pour vous oui on peut
dire ça et puis on peut dire que je
pense qu'il fallait que je passe par ce
spectacle de bercy qui était vraiment un
spectacle très particulier pour pouvoir
enfin faire ce que les choses en plus
grande liberté et sans avoir je dire pas
d'obligation mais bon j'étais très
triste pour bercy là j'ai envie d'être
plus joyeuse et de faire des choses qui
ne correspondent plus maintenant et
voilà donc c'est ça c'est un spectacle
complètement différent c'est pas bercy
en pétillent à ça n'a rien à voir il ne
reste rien au programme il y même
l'homélie parmi les commandes et très
des chansons et composé par michel
berger ou dos à oui oui oui oui ça c est
certaine que vous n'aviez jamais
interprété sur scène
oui parce que parce que bon je me fais
vraiment plaisir en faisant ce spectacle
c'est la première fois que j'ai pensé
d'abord à moi avant de penser au public
les gens qui viendront voir mais en
revanche en faisant ces trois chansons
que j'ai jamais chanté mais que emc là
c'est la raison pour laquelle je les
fais je sais qu'il les aime ces chansons
donc voilà c'est un échange la scène
c'est rien d'autre que ça vous disiez
tout à l'heure on change tout vu par
rapport à bercy nouveau groupe nouvel
habillage musical
nous avions obtenu copie à l'ego ce beau
et les garçons qui chante et qui danse
des nouveaux musiciens et puis on veut
on a essayé de faire du beau avec très
peu de choses très peu de projecteur par
exemple c'est plus difficile de faire un
beau spectacle très peu de projecteur
plutôt qu'avait dit mais ça oblige à se
creuser un peu plus donc en fait on sait
tous ce creuset quoi se tourner et et
travaillez vous vous revenez belgique 2
6e c est pas si c'est vrai ça s'est très
bien passé et paris est une étape c'est
vrai j'ai pas pensé à faire paris je
voulais faire une tournée je voulais
chanter sur scène et voilà à propos des
tableaux d'un mot pourquoi cette envie
de partir aux états unis vous ne sentez
pas pu bien en france à paris non je
déteste la france
non c'est parce qu'il faut jeu il faut
que mes enfants apprennent la langue
américaine anglaise et qui fait meilleur
aux états unis
côté climat est plus en plus mon fils a
toujours eu envie d'être américain et
puis là-bas je vais pouvoir faire de la
musique parce que c'est vraiment un pays
pour faire de la musique
donc je vais vous faire d'utile et
l'agréable et partir quelques mois mais
les avions maintenant tout ça ok mais
parle pas vraiment merci beaucoup france
gall donc je rappelle le pleyel pour
cinq soirs à partir de demain et ensuite
une tournée dans les principales villes
de france
voilà avant avant le grand départ
provisoire aux états unis